[Applause]
people have told me I have saved their
life I became a s more artist or YouTube
because I deal with my own pain each day
ASMR has truly helped me focus on living
instead of dying I ask my artists as
someone who focused mainly on visual
triggers and sounds to bring you some
type of relaxation some of the
misconceptions that people have with
ASMR is thinking that is creepy this
prin G is weird and I believe the reason
why some people believe that is more so
we're discussing constantly but when is
noises listen is to bring you to that
safe place it's to make you feel call I
find my sounds in any and everything
that I do if I'm opening up a pack of
gum if I'm brushing my hair
people love for it sounds like the
people video I don't know what happens
why does eating a pickle causes a person
bring to shut down but it will I have a
degenerative bone disease I can't stop
it there's no cure before I discover is
the more I could not
moon didn't have the script to make
myself stand up so when I discovered
ASMR I felt extremely relaxed I feel
like I was actually smiling just laying
there I felt really really good mentally
more so than being on medication and I
saw okay I'm going to create a channel
and I'm gonna create a smarter videos
because there's a lot of people who are
dealing with stress and sanyas anxiety
we just need some comfort to get them
through tonight I receive email from
people who are bedridden and let me know
how much I have helped them I always
told my children one person could have
changed the world and to actually be a
part of maybe some type of change and
some type of way is amazing
[Music]
[Music]
you